dying light got some new life with the
following expansion thanks to a new map
new vehicles and a bunch of new weapons
and if you know where to look for it
you'll also find a reference that's sure
to please Harry Potter fans as
originally posted on imager one player
found a location that looks an awful lot
like the boy wizard's dingy room and yes
it is under a staircase youtube user the
generic brit got some footage of himself
driving to the easter eggs location
sadly it's not located on privet drive
but if you pay a visit to this homage to
JK Rowling's classic books you'll spot a
ghost on the way out it looks a bit like
the spirits found at Hogwarts don't you
think this isn't the first easter egg
dying light players have found they've
also spotted the master sword a loot
cave and a ray mccall action figure just
to name a few if you're looking for more
info on any of those Easter eggs or
Harry Potter or dying light or more DLC
then you're already in the right place